stop by writing down the equation to be
they provide you with a quadratic this
is as simple as it gets really all they
were to do is classify it they just want
you to tell me what is this quadratic
what kinds of properties does it match
okay so the particular one it should be
is y equals x squared minus 4x plus 4 so
we want to become very comfortable with
working out this description right just
give it an equals okay there's my B
squared right
or my being father so if B squared is 16
minus 4 a c AC sorry 100 K now here that
so I'm getting zero out of that right
now without having factorized this tells
us what it has it's number one it's got
a double root right that makes sense
doesn't it because this guy up here is
actually a perfect square you can
factorize it now can you now that I'm
asking you to
what's the factorization in this guy X X
minus 2 all squared okay so it has that
double root at x equals two so now when
you look at the question it says
evaluate the discriminant which we have
done and determine whether the following
functions are positive definite negative
definite or indefinite okay now
immediately having worked this out I
know I'm not definite because I need to
have a negative value right so all I
need to say is
if I had gotten a negative value like
suppose at this point I got maybe one or
maybe before as I got in these cases
right
what would I then go on to do I know
it's definite how do I know it positive
or negative where am I going to look
yeah I'm going to look up here right so
on my bucket there's a 1 there right so
it's going to be concave up so it would
be if it were definite it would be
positive definite in this case it's
pretty supportive and like I said that's
as simple as it gets
they just give you a quadratic and they
ask you to classify it let's have a look
at question six looks a little more
involved
yeah thanks a lot okay no you can see I
mean we're gonna take advantage of
exactly the same concept right but it's
a little worn Bowl this quadratic here
right we're not sure what it is because
K it can vary right and in fact they
want us to work out different values of
K that will give us different properties
for this quadratic okay so the very
first step with questions like this when
you try to work out positive negative
definite you always need to start with
the description and in fact they even
guide you in that direction okay when
you get a disastrous mess like this okay
number one this is not that bad because
it's already been factorized for you
it's in general form do you see that so
to make it really obvious let's
highlight what's the different
coefficients are okay you do this just
to make it less mental effort for you to
work out b squared minus 4ac you don't
want to have to be keeping that all in
your head you want whatever it now to
tell you that right so now that I have
this and like I said sometimes I'll give
it to you in a not factorized form and
then you have to put it into this form
now that I have it there I'm just going
to compute b squared minus 4ac don't
forget to catch this whole thing it's
very easy to miss out there too for
instance so B squared in this case will
be there's B squared I squared the two
as well which is why I became a 4 minus
4 there's a and there's C now you look
at what they're actually I asked you for
they have actually given us a result for
this discriminant in a simplified form
so it's our responsibility to factorize
this expand this out of it and then
simplify okay so I've got my factor of 4
at the front and they had the factor of
4 already pulled out so I might as well
stick that out the front format escape
or squared who could explain for me we
cannot explain this right
16 - 8 k plus K squared good that's all
done
yes I'm just gonna multiply both by 4
watch out for that negative sign so what
am I gonna get you - 12 okay taking out
a factor of 4
watch out right plus 20 yeah
are you happy with that okay so do you
see what I did catch it when I wrote
down this 4 out the front that's why I
no longer have to account for this 4 or
this for right so what I was doing here
was multiplying out these guys saddle
right and then I watched for the same
you will be so far okay by the way just
a quick note right why don't we focus on
right now we're focusing on all this
stuff
right the algebra is just a given this
is why we start off the year and why in
five three last year's like a kick
algebra algebra you don't want to worry
about mucking up signs or constants all
that kind of thing let's simplify show
me for still out the front it will put
our squared term out here what am i
mentioning terms in most we can also do
six is that match so I'm gonna say as
required
okay fantastic let's have a look at the
different parts on what they want us to
sure right first and as it says find the
values of K what it knows of K you know
they are such that you've got this guy
being positive definite okay so let's
think about this right for positive
definite I need to be two conditions
right here we go
I need to have this guy it's got to be
positive and I've got to have this time
okay so I have two inequalities that I
must satisfy right let's start with the
easy one first a right cuz a was given
to us
there that's quite simple so I've got
three K minus five has to be greater
than zero that's got to be positive to
make it concave up and then I've got
this guy the discriminant for K squared
minus 20 K plus 6 that has to be
negative so I don't get any roots so
just to help you see what's going on
this is the leading coefficient and this
is the discriminant
and this is what I must satisfy such
that for positive definite that's okay
now just pause for a second what's going
to happen what's going to emerge what do
you anticipate will happen before you
just start crunching through your
algebra
okay yeah okay I have to recall these
right now right so I want both of them
at the same time I need this and this
right so this is the first thing I don't
okay
secondly just have a look at this guy
for a second all right have a look this
is a quadratic in k k is the variable
right is it concave up or concave down
it's concave up wait to see that so like
I don't know what this is going to look
like yet but I'm expecting something
kind of like this I have no idea what
these are gonna be and I want the parts
that are negative right you see that and
so which part of this traveler is
negative it's the bit in the middle
right it's this sky that's the part I'm
interested now that will give me an
inequality but then I also have to
satisfy this inequality right so then
I'll look at both of these together and
I want the what's the word for it that's
women I I want the intersection between
these two employees so they both to be
satisfied the same time okay so I'm
gonna give you a few minutes I'm gonna
let you crash through and then after
your head stop I'll show you